Je récapitule la commande, on a dit un double cheese saignant
une grande bouteille d'eau, une frite et un milkshake vanille
Ce sera sur place ou à...
...emporter.
Ok, excusez-moi un petit instant, désolé.
Camille, qu'est-ce tu fais sur Paris ?
C'est maman qui m'a dit où tu travaillais...
D'accord...
Prends ça et va t'installer, je te rejoins.
- Pauline ?
- Ouais ?
Je prends une pause, tu peux t'occuper de la dame ?
Oui, bien sûr.
Ah c'est lui ton ...
Ouais, c'est mon frère...
*respiration stressée*
Un peu avant la fermeture
tu rentres, tu fais ton truc, et tu ressors.
- Ok...
- Rapide et simple.
Après, tu m'appelles.
T'as de la batterie ?
Ouais, ouais...
Tiens.
Juste au cas où...
C'est un vrai ?
Bon...
Qu'est-ce que tu fais ici ?
En fait j'avais rendez-vous sur Paris
Mais j'ai loupé mon train.
Du coup maman m'a dit que je pouvais dormir chez toi.
Heu ... Ouais, oui, bien sûr.
Par contre j'ai un truc de prévu ce soir, c'est assez important
ça te dérange pas de rester tout seul ce soir à l'appart ?
La fille du temps, c'est quoi ?
En fait c'est une fille qui doit trouver des reliques à travers les époques
avec une machine à voyager dans le temps.
Y'a un éditeur qui à bien aimé mon premier livre, c'est pour ça que j'étais sur Paris.
Attends, t'as sorti un livre ?
Ouais, sur internet.
Y'avait pas mal de téléchargements en plus.
Et ton rendez-vous s'est bien passé ?
Ils ont dit que mon histoire manquait d'un truc mais...
ils y connaissaient pas grand chose.
Ça s'est mal passé quoi.
Tu fais quoi là ?
Ça tu vois, c'est une petite fille qui s'est réveillé dans un corps de papy
et là du coup elle part à la recherche de son vrai corps avec sa valise rose...
Arrête Camille, c'est un vieux qui ramène la valise de sa petite fille , je sais pas
mais on ne prend pas en photo les gens comme ça, ça se fait pas
À qui je pourrais demander où sont les toilettes ?
À moi parce que je travaille ici, je suis manager
Bref, c'est la porte au fond là-bas
*sonnerie de téléphone*
Salut Sonia , joyeux anniversaire !
Merci ! Je voulais juste être sûre que t'aies bien la playlist.
Ouais bien sûr, tout est prêt , t'inquiète pas
Putain mais Camille arrête !
Ça va ? C'était quoi ce bruit ?
Non rien c'est mon petit frère qui me fout la honte.
Quoi ? J'savais pas que t'avais un petit frère. Mais c'est hyper mignon.
Oui j'ai un petit frère.
Là il est en galère du coup je l'aide un peu, enfin...
tu vois c'est mon frère, je vais pas le laisser à la rue.
Oui évidemment. Ramène-le ce soir du coup, moi ça me ferait hyper plaisir de le rencontrer.
Ah, non... déjà bon c'est pas le petit frère mignon
Déjà il est grand et puis il aime pas quand il y a du monde.
Mais ramène-le je te dis !
- Sonia y'a un problème avec ton four
Oui, attends y'a un problème il faut que je file, désolée. Bisous !
D'accord à ce soir, bisous
Ça se trouve en fait il y a encore les fils mais
...et les fils sont invisibles, oui j'ai compris
Tu veux sortir ce soir ?
*sonnerie*
Ça va bien se passer.
Tu évites de raconter tes...
Et si tu parles avec Sonia, tu lui racontes des trucs genre on s'entend bien
on jouait ensemble quand on était petit, tout ça, ok?
Mais on jouait ensemble quand on était petit.
Super, tu lui racontes ça
Bonjour Sonia je jouais avec mon frère quand on était petit.
Excusez-nous madame, on s'est trompé d'étage en fait on a une soirée.
Non c'est bien ici.
Sonia, c'est pour toi !
Si ça se trouve c'est une porte qui mène vers le futur.
Là on a vu future Sonia et maintenant on va voir si son futur mari, c'est toi
Ça marche.
Hey, salut !
Mamie je te présente Dimitri et... son frère.
Voilà... on y va ? Entrez.
Par contre vous vous ressemblez pas du tout.
Ils ont pas inversé des bébés à la maternité ou un truc comme ça ?
Haha ! Non non...
Elle blague.
Et toi Camille tu fais quoi?
En fait j'écris une histoire de voyage dans le temps et
(interrompt son frère) : Dans le voyage ! Il est dans le voyage, une agence de voyage.
Cool, bienvenue.
Dim, tu veux mettre la playlist s'il-te-plaît ?
Ouais, j'arrive.
Ça va le faire, OK ?
Tu parles, tu danses.
Si tu sais pas quoi faire tu copies les gens, d'accord?
*Halètement*
Allez !
Oh putain... Fait chier.
Oh putain, on va avoir l'air de deux cons, je t'ai envoyé le lien de cette robe.
Non mais... attends, regarde
Si je mets cette veste
j'ai extrêmement chaud, mais on est pas habillées pareilles.
Mais laisse tomber je vais...
Si ça se trouve c'est une entreprise qui fait exprès de
créer les mêmes habits pour briser les amitiés
- C'est bon t'es prête ?
- Oui je suis prête vas-y.
Oh ! Mais non !
- C'est quoi d'après toi ?
- Je sais pas je me demande !
Et donc cette fille elle doit trouver des reliques à travers les époques
avec sa machine à voyager dans le temps.
Mais bon ils m'ont dit que mon histoire manquait d'un truc.
C'est un peu vague comme retour.
Vous dites si je vous ennuie avec mes histoires Henriette ?
Non pas du tout, c'est juste que c'est un peu tard pour moi.
Je vais fermer les yeux si ça t'embête pas mon petit gars.
Non, pas du tout.
Vous savez où sont les toilettes ?
*Bruit de soirée étouffé*
C'était mon idée, j'en avais parlé aux autres que tu voulais en faire.
- Ah... La guitare ? Oui.
- Oui du coup on a fait un cadeau commun
Merci, ça m'a hyper touché, c'était hyper mignon, merci.
Tu sais, je voulais te demander si tu...
*sonnerie*
- ...tu voulais bien...
- Vas-y décroche !
Non vas-y je te jure décroche, t'inquiète pas pour moi, je vais voir avec des potes.
Ouais c'est normal, c'est ton anniversaire, je comprends.
- Oui ?
- Ouais... T'es où ?
Je suis dans la cuisine t'es où toi ?
J'aimerais rentrer en fait.
Quoi déjà ?
Ouais, je préfère être à la maison.
Mais non mais ça vient juste de commencer.
Tu sais tu peux rester ici, moi je peux aussi rentrer tout seul.
Mais non mais reste, profite, parle avec des gens, voilà.
J'ai parlé un peu avec Henriette.
Mais non mais tu fais comme les autres, tu danses, tu profites, voilà.
Ça m'amuse pas.
Tu peux pas être comme tous le monde un petit peu ?
T'aurais un chargeur ?
T'aurais un chargeur toi ? Non ?
Bonjour salut ?
T'aurais un chargeur pour mon téléphone ?
Non, mais je crois que tu t'es trompé de soirée surtout.
- Donc ça va pas être possible.
- Juste reste tranquille.
- Tu vas te calmer parce que t'es chez moi là ! Ok ?
- C'est quoi le problème ?
Ça va je veux juste charger mon téléphone, laissez-moi tranquille.
Ok, tu sais quoi ? On appelle les flics alors.
Non non, tu fais rien du tout. Personne ne bouge !
Personne ne bouge !
Éteins la musique toi, éteins la musique !
Toi, viens-là, viens-là.
Va avec les autres, tu vas avec les autres.
Personne ne bouge, tu bouges pas !
Tu fais quoi là ? Tu fais quoi ?
Tu fais quoi ? Viens là !
Allez là-bas vous. Allez là-bas !
Je veux personne aux fenêtres, et personne appelle les flics !
Sortez vos téléphones là, tous. Tous.
Sortez vos téléphones là !
Allez jetez-les par terre !
Si je vois quelqu'un utiliser son téléphone, je le fume !
Ok ? Je le fume.
Et filez-moi un putain de chargeur là, bordel !
Vous bougez pas !
Putain...
Allez allume-toi.
Qu'est-ce que vous faites là ?
Mettez vous là, je veux tous vous voir.
Il faut que je vous vois tous.
Putain !
*Halètements très nerveux*
Vous auriez pas dû faire ça.
Et ferme-là toi !
Tu la fermes !
Vous devriez partir maintenant.
Je crois qu'on peut descendre dans la rue en utilisant cette fenêtre.
Vous devriez vraiment partir d'ici avant qu'ils vous tombent dessus.
Non mais ta gueule, ils vont pas m'avoir cette fois-ci, personne va me tomber dessus.
Ah mais... Je parle pas de la police.
Non, techniquement si la police vous tombe dessus vous seriez en sécurité.
Non mais tu comprends pas ? Je veux pas t'entendre !
Je veux pas t'entendre !
Ah putain...
Vous pensez que c'est une soirée normale ? Je comprends.
Mais non.
Vous êtes juste tombé sur la mauvaise soirée, je suis désolé pour vous.
Oh putain ! Tu te tais !
Tu te tais.
Ce soir on fête les 70 ans de Mama.
Mama c'est une vieille tueuse à gages
qui a pris sous son aile des orphelins pour en faire des assassins...
Tu crois que tu vas me faire peur ?
Peur ? Elle ?
Elle connaît pas la peur.
À 8 ans elle vit toute seule dans une forêt en Sibérie.
Dans la neige, elle se nourrit uniquement de bêtes sauvages.
Depuis... La peur ça existe plus pour elle.
Vous pensez qu'elle a peur là ? Mais non.
Elle cherche uniquement un moyen de vous exterminer.
Parce que... elle aime prendre son temps.
T'es un malade toi.
Allume-toi... allume-toi.
Allez-y, vérifiez par vous-même et dites-moi si elle a l'air d'avoir peur.
Tu commences sérieusement à me casser les-
*chuchotent*
- J'ai toujours ça...
- C'est quoi ?
Des écouteurs.
Ça téléphone toujours.
Camille : Elle réfléchit
elle réfléchit calmement à quel de ses orphelins assassins
elle va envoyer pour vous supprimer de l'existence.
Oui parce que ces gens-là, ils ne vous tuent pas.
Ils vous font disparaître.
Mais sérieusement, des orphelins c'est quoi cette histoire là ?
D'abord il y a Sergeï, Sergeï dit l'Ours.
C'est un brun un peu moche avec un manteau en fourrure.
Camille : Lui à l'adolescence, il a été forcé à tuer et dépecer un ours
en pleine nature, tout seul dans la neige.
Ça lui a pris deux jours.
Sonia : Mets le manteau !
Avec la peau de l'ours, il s'est fait un manteau qu'il quitte jamais.
Sa spécialité c'est l'arme blanche.
- Fais l'air méchant !
- Mais pourquoi ?
Fais l'air méchant !
Tu me dis de la merde, il a pas une tête de psychopathe ton mec
il a une tête de naze.
Mais ça c'est parce que Mama elle fait en sorte qu'ils ressemblent à tous le monde
pour mieux s'infiltrer.
- C'est logique.
- Bien-sûr.
Par exemple il y a Sonia l'Angélique.
Sonia elle a deux personnalités.
L'une, sage qui étudie le journalisme.
Et l'autre, une sociopathe qui étrangle ses victimes.
Quand sa deuxième personnalité est éveillée, faut faire attention
elle a comme un tic à l’œil droit.
Vite vite ! C'est bien.
Ok !
Alors ? Sa personnalité...
C'est laquelle ?
C'est la deuxième.
Vous avez vraiment pas de chance vous.
Allez allume-toi bordel.
En même temps vous interrompez un moment super important.
Je sais de source sûre qu'un échange d'argent était prévu ce soir.
Des billets de 500€.
- Vite 500€ Personne a 500€ ?!!
Sergeï a récupéré le butin en échange de ses services
et il a caché l'argent dans les toilettes.
PQ ! Théo ! PQ !
Il a besoin du magot pour se construire une nouvelle vie.
Sergeï avait prévu de partir avec l'argent dans un étui à guitare.
parce que plus tôt dans la matinée
il a tué son propre frère.
Et avant d'arriver ce soir
il s'est débarrassé du corps dans des sacs poubelles.
On raconte que le corps est encore chaud.
Mais le problème, c'est les jumelles Olive.
Elles sont prêtes à tout pour voler l'argent.
Les jumelles Olive c'est deux soeurs
qui ont pour habitude de se faire passer pour la même personne.
Elles utilisent les mêmes habits quoi.
Comme ça elles peuvent poignarder dans le dos et dans le ventre au même moment.
C'est pas joli à voir.
Et ce qu'elles savent pas les jumelles Olive
c'est que Sonia et Sergeï s'aiment d'un amour passionnel et interdit depuis des années.
Donc pour protégter Sergeï, Sonia s'apprêtait à étrangler les jumelles Olive.
Mais c'est là que vous êtes intervenu et que...
Vous les empêchez de régler leur comptes. En plus...
Je crois qu'il reste de la place dans les sacs poubelles.
*Musique angoissante*
*Raclement de gorge*
Madame Mama.
Je tenais à m'excuser pour...
Je savais pas pour vos trucs. J'ai rien vu.
Je vais y aller.
Et surtout vous inquiétez pas, si la police arrive nous on va pas vous balancer.
On a notre honneur.
C'est un peu dans notre sang.
Ouais parce que je vous ai pas dit mais
Sergeï, Sonia, les jumelles Olive et moi
On vient d'une autre planète.
Quoi ?
En fait notre vaisseau s'est écrasé sur terre et Mama nous a recueilli
pour nous aider à retourner sur notre planète qui est derrière la lune
- Ce qui fait que en fait
- C'est quoi ce bruit ?
on est un peu tous ici des orphelins assassins et alien.
C'est quoi ça ?
Vous vous foutez de ma gueule ou quoi ?
C'est quoi ces conneries d'alien là ?
Qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Putain !
Il dit la vérité !
Zanorg !
*joue très très mal*
Tu peux pas dévoiler notre secret et notre identité comme ça.
Tu sais comment sont les humains ils veulent nous capturer
et nous disséquer.
Je suis désolé d'avoir trahis notre famille.
Mais tu dois faire attention à toi et à ton enveloppe...
Enveloppe corporelle.
Enveloppe corporelle voilà.
Zanorg, mon frère.
Pardonne-moi... On va réparer le vaisseau et
rentrer chez nous derrière la Lune sur la planète...
Xantia.
Monsieur, libérez mon frère
Il a rien fait.
J'ai besoin de lui pour reconstruire le vaisseau.
- Police ! On a des questions !
Allez-y.
Allez-y c'est maintenant allez !
*reprend son souffle*
Oh putain.
Ça va ?
Mais... C'est une voiture.
De quoi ?
Xantia c'est le nom de la voiture de papa, c'est pas une planète.
Ouais bon je fais avec ce que j'ai.
T'es con.
- J'ai rien vu de particulier...
Oh ma chérie.
T'as commandé des strip-teaseurs ?
Camille !
Bonjour
Moi c'est pas du tout pour une dédicace
c'est plus pour vous donner un petit coup de main
parce que j'ai relevé une incohérence dans l'histoire
Comment ça une incohérence ? C'est-à-dire ?
Excusez-moi monsieur vous entendez quoi par incohérence ?
Démetra ne peux pas voyager dans le temps avec la relique.
Mais bien-sûr que si Démetra peux faire ça !
Elle est pas de la même temporalité, c'est le principe même !
Ah ok d'accord.
Bonjour Monsieur.
- La relique vient déjà du passé !
C'est pour votre frère.
- La cité des mondes et les mondes se croisent, c'est fait pour ça !
- Alors oui on est d'accord avec la station Xanrax
- Sauf que non, quand ils voyagent dans le temps il ne sont pas sur Xanrax
- Mais c'est le principe même de cet endroit !
Mais ils ne sont plus sur la première planète !
Mais ça n'est plus une question de planète c'est juste la temporalité !
C'est le voyage de la relique avec des règles !
- Non il est clairement énoncé par Joshua
- Alors, Joshua, parlons-en !
Joshua dit que ça ne s'applique pas à la planète Fluxor...
Fluxor n'a rien à voir là dedans ! #Jambon